[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys we've got Ryan and
Joe we got Bart and Nick we got steveen
me and I just took Ryan's intro all
right that's my intro that's your intro
you say everybody's names very very
empathetic and amazing of you dude my
new intro is fire by the way wait for
all then way better than stay right now
just wait for it wait for it all all
right well back to careful boys will we
currently fear
everyone that's good too we'll never
measure up man I like the variation for
the rest of our lives everyone okay so
what is your I can't wait for your
answer what is your favorite thing about
your
ethnicity oh aside from being the master
race barbecues oh wait I said that out
loud you also said it
loud out loud and loud
okay what is it about uh being the
master race that you like well I'd like
to First clarify that my idea of Japan
is very much the
same as any kid growing up in America
I'm I'm a bit of a wee right so like I
make up my ideas of Japan okay and my
and my only window is from my
relatives and what they've told me Japan
is about which
wasal but isn't that that's the only
thing that actually matters is what you
think it is because that's how you live
life sure yeah yeah that's true what
what do you like about it what are some
benefits you've seen I think they're so
gay that's the benefit no I'm just
kidding um that's what you
like I love how
well they all rebranded after World War
II to the point where people don't even
remember the stain well I bet some
Koreans and Taiwanese and people do but
the most of the world like when you
think of Germany right I mean they
haven't done a great job after Hitler
people still remember Hitler yeah they
didn't Rebrand that well big
time to the point where like yeah it's
kind of like oh they might do it again I
don't know right where Japan is like
they're harmless they [__] smell
dirty underwear and they just like anime
and they're all [__] weak you're
right you know so like weak and people
don't have that same mentality and you
you like that about your ethnicity that
they did a Rebrand a big Rebrand yeah I
like I like how people don't even know
how [__] how Savage it was pre World
War I there were just a bunch of savage
Warlords killing each other off all day
and their war war crimes is covered up
by Pikachu yeah Pikachu is the best
Rebrand and Sony real answer dude
because I think it's just interesting
how much they flipped it on its back is
everything that happened by Design so
all this like [__] no I think people
reacted opposite to what happened cuz
they were lied to so imagine like back
then so you know how like we see Isis
and [__] like that right yeah so they
were telling so my uncle was actually a
part of like you know how Hitler had the
Hitler Youth mhm they had the same
programming for the Youth out there in
Japan and they were telling everybody
that the emperor is um has de like God
powers and if you commit suicide for the
country you'll come back and you'll be
like you'll go to heaven and all this
stuff so that's why the comicazi and all
that [__] the kids they had 14-year-old
kids not only in Planes but in submarine
missiles just [__] di the missiles
they were they were in a missile bro
like why did they have to be in the
missile so the worst job you could get
they didn't have autopilot yet yet they
their autopilot was an actual human
being they had steering wheels inside
the missiles yeah kids are just like ah
Jesus it was fun right before the death
yeah going fast dude cuz at the end of
it they're just like well we can only
shoot so much we might as well get these
kids coming in and doing bombs and
whatever right so then once they lost
everyone was like wait how can we lose
like our our God is the emperor and we
were the master race and how did we lose
that doesn't make any sense and then so
after that they're like well [__] the
government then and then I think it was
like we should we should be super
anti-war and they don't they're not very
Waring at all so I think it oh so the
the image change was actually result of
like revolting against the current I
think so I think everybody was like I
don't want to [__] that war is stupid
it's horrible like I don't want to do
that ever again well didn't like the US
take their military too we're like yeah
you guys aren't going to have military
yeah so all the responsibilities on the
US yeah but I I I don't know that was my
that was what was told to me so then
that was like probably my parents and my
uncle and everybody in their generation
that were like yeah war is bad it's
horrible look at what it did to our
country look at what it did to whatever
and they're like but then look at what
peace did to your birth
rate
oh so that's your favorite thing do you
have any advice for Germany on how they
can like work re you can just talk to me
if you want anime I'm pretty anime
German anime dude yeah cute cartoons are
cute cartoons that's a huge one that's a
good one and scrumptious food okay yeah
Germany ain't really got that you got
sourkraut Pokemon sh actually the the
sausages are really [__] good in
German sausages this is Pikachu the brat
worst are good V I've been to Germany I
had the browers was very good pork
knuckle if I if I had to be
100% real I would have to say um this is
even pre-World War II right so the way
that when people get into [__] they
obsess about it and they make it like a
life's their whole life is about this
thing and they try to perfect it h I
think that's very telling of the the way
they approach work and lifestyle yeah
cool it's pretty I agree I love that I
love that too to the point where the
reality seems skewed because it's almost
like when you see larpers in America or
like the Civil War reenacting people
right you can tell that they're doing
that on the weekend whereas like if
Japan got into that never turns off that
becomes reality yeah yeah that's what I
respect the most about Japanese I think
is whatever they do they go hard they
can even do it better than who invented
it yeah yeah yeah right they like holy
[__] everyone coming back from Japan
they're like I had the best pizza of my
life they perfect things if they touch
it it's better than where the source
came from oh dude techology a part of
religion I got a facial from a lady
something it's the worst version
of but they made it quick though they
made it so quick they're all about
quantity not quality you can get 20 of
them but they're good at quantity yes
very good that might be my favorite
thing about China
quantity let's hear from uh from Steve
Green yeah so what didn't we do um
you're welcome for the lights in the
room and all kinds of [__]
right um probably we made the camera
probably and
sound sound made sound well we made you
know we like whatever that they invented
sound
probably yeah it's pretty sweet up
here we got it all does it is it uh do
you like when you look at it right like
do you
go do you see it as like Europeans are
on your team too or do you see it as
like American because for me I think
like
fresh immigrant still in my head where I
have that tie going to Japan my mom
still lives there so then it's like um I
can still identify with it right whereas
like like you you don't have any family
in Europe so like on the real when I was
in Germany I was like this place sucks
and the it was R cold when I was there I
don't feel connection with like Germans
even though that's where like a l my
from and [__] I don't I I do feel
strongly about them but they weren't
there there that's why it sucks the
Third Reich is gone but no I I mean I'm
I'm just an American and I I feel that
way about basically everyone in this
room as well it's like we're all just
Americans and like it's like you know
how much can we really say cuz if we
went over there they're all like you're
not from here [__] you they [__] us yeah
so there's a lot of that funny stuff
going on but plus you got a Japanese
tattoo now so I do have a Japanese
tattoo a wrong Japanese man of the world
now yeah um so that's going to be really
fun too by the way um when people going
to think I'm a [__] white poser doing
like japanes but that's your dream bro I
love it I think the best part is is it's
intentional that's what some people
don't get like that's your [__]
that's my thing
dude I know like yeah I'm like inside of
a sarcasm bubble right now I can't wait
but no um there is no like white
Alliance I feel yeah well sure you're
perpetuated that yeah well exactly but I
mean you know real or funny right you
want me to be real or funny but but
right now like there is no like I don't
know man like um what I really admire
about what you guys have is like you
guys like have like a [__] brand ID
almost and you guys can like talk about
things in a certain way like there's
like a underlying almost kinship with
things whereas white people were just
like I don't know where did you where
did you come from and [__] like do we
all watch Nickelodeon as a kid yes but
like there's no like um oh yeah like my
family back in Germany they're all like
this like we're all just so integrated
oh like an extra stream that ties
everyone together yeah there's none of
that it's like it's like I was wondering
if Europeans would have that cuz
Hannah kind of has that but it's
regional it's from a completely
different place like Wales yeah that's
what I mean like Europe whatever like
where they're still connected kind of
well look at them yelling at soccer
right like like they're all like my my
buddy is like from the UK and he's like
a DieHard [__] you know football fan
whatever but they go territorial like
England versus Wales versus all this
[__] I'm like isn't that the same thing
he's like no dude it's like just
saw boy what but I'm like you I don't
you mad whereas here what do I have
right it's like you have the C I have
the Cults so then like I hate the
Patriots so kind same thing football
stuff is kind of like that right and
then um but then the Patriots don't even
recognize us they they like we're like
the guy that they killed in every war
and so they don't even respect us but
it's kind of there is no like um I don't
know I'm trying to think it's like
there's not like a I know with the The
Stereotype is like like the Dave
Chappelle sketch like like behind closed
doors where all like have St handshakes
and [__] but like there is none of that
like a new white neighborhood neighbor
moves in you're like Hey Brother let's
go and [__] whereas you guys like if you
guys have an Asian move in you guys get
excited about it yeah I can see that
true different thing don't you like
bring over cast roll and [__] nah dude
that's all just memes and like
stroganov I guess in in Virginia where I
was growing up like one of my neighbors
would do like um pizza night where he
would make the pizza in like a like his
oven that's cool yeah that's Italian the
neighbor but the whole neighborhood was
different I had Koreans in the
neighborhood I had a um like um my
neighbor was cantones and [__] or it
reminds me of that Tom sigura bit when
when he does he's talking about at the
park and then he goes like why people
don't have that same type of we we'll
fight for you cuz it some guy oh yeah
yeah yeah he was like he said the nword
and then all these black FS popped out
of the bushes to beat him up and then he
was like white people just look at each
other like I don't know this guy
remember that video we all just saw of
that brawl on the pier oh yeah yeah
that's the same [__] it's like that
those black guys were getting beat that
black guys getting beat up and then
those black guys came into his rescue
right cuz it's just like oh that's we
have a thing we're we're buds we're
going to help each other but then all
the white people were from the same boat
yeah that's true there were no like
stragglers that came in no other whites
no secondary same boat yeah so yeah it
is interesting to see that I do like
think it's cool that you guys have that
but like yeah I don't you know yeah
there's definitely a builtin like thing
which's weird to me because even the
whole Asian Alliance thing is a new
thing like back in Asia Asians yeah
that's that's still new like in Asia
doesn't exist you know what I mean like
like if in Asia like you don't jump in
for another or like you don't think of
it that way you think of yourself
separately like you're a whole entire
different race and then like that's an
Asian-American thing yeah it is I it is
I think it's
very oddly Asian-American or Asians in
english- speaking countries
it's probably the same thing where like
maybe in 10 generation diaspora thing
yeah when when it's like several
Generations in and we have no connection
to Asia anymore I think it's going to be
the same way because we're going to
think more like independently rather
than collectively but there is like you
guys can like for example you guys do
stereotypical stuff all the time and you
can do that and people don't assume the
worst if I do a stereotypical if I say
stereotype thing yeah unironically
people will hate on me right because
just cuz I'm a white dude and so it's
like I don't really care that much cuz
it's stereotypes stuff is kind of hack
anyway that everything you do is an
assumed down punch yeah exactly which is
a little bit like it's like where did
this come from cuz like I mean it
doesn't bother me cuz like I said most
stereotyped stuff is just hack anyway so
I could I could do I could probably
figure something else out but but it is
kind of like man it is it does suck when
like people are just joke joke bombing
stuff and then like they're just like
whoa not you buddy like right too far
it's the same [__] bit same bit
that's true that's my my favorite thing
about Filipinos honestly is that I
really believe there's a built-in thing
in Filipinos that they just have a good
sense of humor that they're able to like
take jokes and they're really good at
like uh bridging gaps like they're
really good at assimilating with uh
connecting with other people like
growing up like Filipino people hung out
with like everybody they like you know
they were like the friends of like the
black crowd the hip-hop crowd they're
the neutral group yeah good at absorbing
culture and like and just being like a
good element of it and that's my
favorite thing is like if I meet a
Filipino guy like anywhere in the world
I know what's going to make us both
laugh you know even if I don't speak the
same language there's always like a
connected like a there's like something
in the core I don't know what how that
got that way but there really is he's
also going to try to steal your girl too
though they're going to they're going to
make you laugh and steal your girl at
the same
time yeah that's my favorite thing is
that I know that they're not going to be
like but at least not maybe now
generation I think if you don't have
that sense of humor where you're just
like a stickler and kind of with
something up your ass that I don't think
you're doing Filipino correctly that's
true you're not you're not doing
Filipino I do think that stereotype is
real though like Filipinos are friendly
I think so so friendly a sad
Filipino that's why I think like you're
you're something's wrong with you man if
you're just like not fun and everyone
hates you you're a sad Filipino boy yeah
or something what was her name was in
here saying that she would never date a
Filipino guy who Jesse yeah oh yeah
she's had a bad run with I think some
Filipino dudes and the Filipino dude is
going to leave you a midm marriage I
mean if it's based on experience nothing
you can really say about that I mean you
are going to have bad experiences and
that's going to shape your opinion but I
think like as a default philipinos are
pretty good at like [__] around which
is nice my uh the thing that I love most
about Chinese is also the thing I hate
most about it what's that so I think
here it comes so what I like about
Chinese that I think is pretty dope is
how Unapologetic they are oh you know
it's like what I'm just copying you know
like they're just just it's just so it's
just so like what situation is that yeah
so like um so practical and like oh
unemotional so things are efficient and
gets done yeah it's like it's like I
have a booger so I'm going to pick it
yeah yeah but then also like this like
this like they'll pick it right and you
look at them like what are you looking
at huh and then they're like this and
then they're like well I guess they're
the most liberated and free person I've
ever met because they don't give a [__]
about anything else but at the same time
because they don't give a [__] about
anything else they also don't give a
[__] about anything around them you know
so so it kind of has like this thing
where it's like um it feels like there's
their culture everyone is just it's like
a car crash out of super market so it
works when it's with themselves but it's
hard to coexist with Chinese people and
it's hard to assimilate but they also
don't have to give a [__] because
they're like the the most populous
[__] ethnic group in the world so
they don't have to coexist with the rest
of the world you know what I'm saying so
they don't need to learn those things
it's like that's why they got their own
[__] social media their own [__]
everything their own governmental system
their own you know ecosystem and they're
like no [__] the world we're big enough
they can join us and that's kind of like
kind of cool even though it's kind of
whack it's funny cuz usually when you
hear people being like racist it's about
other races but every single time I hear
Chinese people talking the most [__]
about Chinese people yeah oh yeah is
there is there a COR is there a
correlation with like with that attitude
and population density for sure think
about like the pride of of of like U
ethnic groups that are like or even like
the Mong people that we were talking
about before right so few of them so
they always have to have certain certain
types of like pride in order to keep
yeah in order to keep that their their
entire history and culture alive or you
you look at like uh Korean Pride that
The Stereotype of Korean Pride after
everything they've been through and
being like you know through war and
everything like that or even the
separation between the North and the
South it's like they have to have strong
amounts of Pride you know what I mean
when they do something in the world that
is like amazing you know so it's kind of
whereas like China you got like 1.
[__] s billion they're like ah he
could die there's 1 million more yeah
you don't have to care as much because
you you're literally like 20% of the
world yeah but there's also something
built into like the culture like you
know how like um like let's say if
there's like a a restaurant if it's a
Japanese restaurant and their rules are
we have four tables here they don't care
that there's a 2hour line outside yeah
I'm so sorry there's only four tables
right right Chinese are like oh my God
you see how many customer out there man
holy [__] don't like [__] hey okay I
serve you you eat on top of this and
then you eat over here you know oh
you're still hungry here take some of
that one like it's just like they don't
give a [__] so so at one point where
it's like that's why it's hard to trust
Chinese people cuz the rules are all
broken like when did you draw this
blueprint was it there in the [__]
copying era or what so there's like one
side like it's hard to trace things back
CU you don't know how legit things are
but at the other side the adaptability
is crazy that's true how much they can
just yeah [__] it man roll with the
punches you know cuz remember when it
was um when they were like if you don't
if you're not vaccinated you can't go
eat in a restaurant it was like this in
California and San Francisco was really
enforcing that [__] so when we were in
San Francisco I was like oh [__] like
where we going to go eat and I was like
I got it
Chinatown Yep they're like [__] man
we make the
virus like if if there's a Japanese
manuscript I would trust it I know
there's honor they're going to make sure
this is the way it's done true if
there's like a Chinese one I'm like man
they probably wrote out a convenience or
I don't know how many like
embellishments there are is Palm [__]
don't worry yeah like this is I'm like
come on dude
yeah that's funny but it's also TI it is
it is that's why I hate it but I also
love it you that's a really good point
that's a very good point but do you all
three identify as like Chinese though or
do you see Chinese and go I ain't
Chinese depends what you're looking at
yeah it depends I know I know I'm a very
specific subsect of like Asian Chinese
American right likeo ameran I'm
definitely way more American than
I yeah dude like cuz you know growing up
like what you say like my mom my family
would always be talking [__] about
Chinese people and the whole time like
growing up I was really actually
confused I was like aren't we [__]
Chinese like what the [__] is going on
but yeah no it's it's very interesting
cuz yeah I don't know I just feel like I
am way more American than I am Chinese
at the end of the day sound American man
[__] you
dude I've been to so many dinners with
like my Chinese friends families where
their parents half of the dinner is just
them talking [__] about Chinese people
yeah that's dinner with my family oh
yeah for sure and I'm just like dude I
remember one time we were eating at a
Chinese restaurant and then there was
like you know like sometimes you're just
into your food and there's silence right
and my friend's mom looks up and she
goes why are Chinese people so [__]
ugly that's just rough dude and the
funny thing is it was like half of the
tables were their relatives and friends
so she's just not only calling Chinese
people ugly she's calling her friends
and family ugly and then we were just
dying in tears laughing and she all like
[__] dude that's so
funny yeah you know sounds like hanging
with family
honestly everywhere you go in the best
sense they're like a virus you know
Chinese virus
they could like go somewhere and then
just [__] create like bacteria and
just [__] you know and there's
something convenient about that create
bacteria you know like you think of like
the entire 66 or like Chinatown like
from LA and how much has gone all the
way out to like [__] it's like the
Inland Empire now just how many Chinese
people around they take over yeah they
just take over a whole area and the
culture is so like you could point to a
random agent be like are you Chinese and
like the percentage of you being correct
pretty hot and there's to that too if
you're a Chinese person you know what
I'm saying unless you're Korean or
Japanese and you get Hella offended cuz
you're like how [__] dare you which
is one of my favorite things the fact
that I won't get offended if somebody's
like Chinese I like cool yeah but if I
said it then you're punching down it's
different [__] up you can't do that
Steve you can't say that Chinese huh hey
dude don't point at me please like I do
love the fact call a chinan Chinese are
everywhere because like I since I grew
up in a Chinese neighborhood Hood I miss
Chinese food so if I'm in Europe or any
any place and I'm just like [__] man I'm
kind of homesick I'll go to a Chinese
restaurant and it's almost the same no
matter where you are in the world and
it's kind of like you get to eat that
and you're like all right cool I'm I'm
I'm reset comforting man infected the
world but the way you put it it's so
fast the way you put it's way more
eloquent it's like a [__] pandemic
it's a [__] virus no it's fine I'm
just sitting here laughing at it that's
that's and you're the bad guy IS
F